bonjour suzanne gare bonjour bienvenue
dans la matinale de rtl france alors le
premier ministre stephan l'ohvn a donc
été renforcée renverser un par un vote
de défiance au parlement
expliquez-nous précisément pour quelles
raisons c'est à dire que il faut revenir
aux élections 2010 huit ans parce que
c'est la hausse a commencé toute cette
histoire et après les élections le
gouvernement a eu beaucoup de problèmes
à former un gouvernement
ç'a pris quatre mois et en janvier 2019
on a fait un accord avec les quatre
partis donc j'ai social-démocrate les
centristes les verts et la gauche mais
sûrement un élu là qu'on voit tout de
suite là et il voulait surtout pas
travailler avec la droite
donc c'était une obligation pour l est
et après donc ils sont faits cet accord
ils sont trouvés 73 paragraphe
oui c'était d'accord pour gouverner
ensemble
et justement ce qui se passe tout de
suite c'est que parmi ces 73 paragraphe
il ya un paragraphe qui parle de loi dit
elle c'est là où la gauche ils sont ils
sont sûrs la possibilité de renverser il
faut dire le gouvernement parce qu' il
n'était pas d'accord avec 7 paragraphe
de faire un marché libre des loyers vous
comprenez ce que je vais dire là je
pense qu'il ya notre expression là en
français c'est à dire que les loyers
sont complètement au marché et il n'y a
pas de réflexion ne sont plus qu assez
riche pour wayne kariwa le passé ça
cesse et justement ce point là c'est
donc un imposteur voilà tout de suite
c'est justement là où elle a pris la
possession qui elle avait pour pour
monter une sorte de méfiance vers le
faire le gouvernement
c'est ça ce qui s'est passé donc on a
fait la vôtre et r et c'était un jour
unique et historique dans la vie
politique aux bugs et justement comment
est-ce que réagissent les suédois face à
se revoir ceux vendus du premier
ministre vous
didier face à un jour historique je
pense que il ya des gens bien sûr qu'ils
sont inquiétés et tout ça mais pour moi
personnellement je sens que ça c'était
attendu parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
problèmes
beaucoup de compromis entre les parties
parce que c'était tout porte sur la
question d'explorer la droite l'extrême
droite et c'est très difficile quand
même avec pour les autres partis
politiques de travailler ensemble et on
voit qu'il ya quelque chose qui craque
et pour moi c'était attendu qui a
quelque chose qui va se passer quand
même
pourquoi c'était attendu de nouveau
parce qu'il y avait trop de compromis on
pouvait pas d un corner
il faut voir que de plus en plus des
partis politiques essayent exclus des
élections guat de plus en plus les gens
votent et montre le soutien pour
l'extrême droite ou qu'il ya quelque
chose qui va pas parce qu'on n'a plus la
confiance dans le gouvernement
si les gens il ya autour de 20% quand
même même plus qui votent pour l'extrême
droite et savent ça fait une situation
très difficile à gérer un
alors stéphane l'ofen a donc une semaine
pour annoncer des élections anticipées
ou alors annoncé sa démission
à quoi est-ce que l'on s'attend en suède
difficile à dire je pense que c'est kif
kif 1 mais peut-être il ya une nouvelle
élection mais c'est compliqué quand même
parce que donc il ya la réalité
élections normaux la miba l'année
prochaine 2022 est donc déjà faire un
élections au mois de septembre ça ça
coûte déjà beaucoup d'argent ça coûte
beaucoup de travail enfin ça dépend
beaucoup de travail est ce qu'il y a des
gens qui veulent vraiment voter ça
pousse beaucoup de questions et vu donc
la situation qui s'est passé après les
élections 2018 et les problèmes que les
partis politiques et au nul pour goût
pour former un gouvernement
je pense que dans huit jours il ya très
peu de chance pour trouver une solution
si donc on s'attend pas née en moi une
démission du premier ministre
difficile à dire je sais pas quand je
vais pas le dire
alors vous le rappeliez en tout cas il
ya des élections législatives en
septembre 2022
est ce que stéphane l'ofen il pourrait
revenir malgré tout au premier plan dans
le paysage politique suédois oui c'est
possible c'est possible pourquoi ce
serait possible et c'est pas la fin de
sa carrière politique finalement
aujourd'hui je pense qui a trait à faya
beaucoup de gens ils sont fatigués de
lui parce qu'il croit même il maintient
possession assez passif de vous le dire
mais dont la situation on s est très
difficile à former un gouvernement c'est
ça le problème est donc il faut voir
s'il ya le secret c'est très limité
entre les deux blocs
entre les deux on la gauche et les verts
et ee est là les centristes et les
libéraux être le dire et la droite donc
la voie il s'essaie de former un nouveau
gouvernement avec un candidat de
ministre de premier ministre mais est ce
qu'ils vont réussir c'était peut-être
été balancés 50 50
eh bien on suivre en tout cas tout cela
de très près merci beaucoup à vous
suzanne gars d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin je rappelle vous
êtes journaliste pour le quotidien or as
cannes